let us start with the fiscal statement
being delayed there was a real need not
that long ago to stay to steady the
markets which was why it was brought
forward from November to the 31st of
October why then are we are we seeing
this delay well I think because the uh
Chancellor and the Prime Minister quite
rightly you've got a new cabinet new
secretary's estate getting familiar with
their departments
um felt that having an Autumn statement
uh on the 17th of November will give
everyone around the table a bit more
time to be able to look carefully
there's not going to be any easy
decisions I can tell you because I've
been there myself been Secretary of
Education of course I was Chancellor for
a short period of time in the summer and
then as Chancellor duchy of Lancaster
the cabinet office the sort of the
operation side of government but what
the Prime Minister wanted to do is make
sure that we um you know Circle back and
look at everything closely the important
thing to remember is as he said
yesterday he'll always be on the side
and he mentioned pensioners of those
most vulnerable in our side here's the
chancellor that delivered the 1200 pound
additional help for the 8 million most
vulnerable households so we'll look at
all of that in the round and the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt will then make
that Autumn statement on the 17th of
November but this is undoubtedly going
to be a prime minister who is going to
have to deliver a significant cuts to
public spending isn't he he said that
yes there's not going to be any ease
decisions you have to step back a second
and think where we are today we have war
on our continent this is a major war we
haven't seen anything like it since the
second world war Putin is using energy
as a weapon not just we saw when I was
in the treasury where gas prices were
spiking so uh suddenly that many
businesses viable businesses were
worried about being put out of business
the energy uh intervention we made has
made a difference but actually he's
using it if you look at what's happening
with food costs because energy then
reflects into food prices so the
chancellor and the Prime Minister are
determined that we send a very clear
message to the markets that we are
financially responsible completely and
we have an energy plan to to be to
deliver that energy security for this
country in the medium term and all of us
understand the necessity to reassure the
markets that's because of what let's
trust and quasi quarantine did um and
look I understand that you are not the
chancellor you are not in a position to
to kind of perhaps be specific on on the
the intimate detail of what is going to
be announced on the 17th of November but
the triple lock on pensions I mean your
colleague Maria Caulfield put it puts it
like this when the government doesn't
confirm one way or another speculation
amounts vacuums are created people start
to worry I've got pensioners who are
worried can you tell us this morning
what will be happening with the triple
law so I think it would be unwise of me
to preempt the Autumn statement uh I
this government is about responsibility
and sustainability what I would say to
pensioners watching this morning is both
the Prime Minister and the chancellor
are very much aware and I'm going to
State the obvious is pensioners are
uniquely unable to work to uh you know
and add to their income
inflation I suggestion it should be tied
to inflation rather than wages so again
it's not in a position to answer that
question it's irresponsible to preempt
an Autumn statement with an Autumn
statement you know we governments wait
until the chance has done the work to be
able to then to make those announcements
in the appropriate and proper way we we
aren't expecting shell you know massive
uh petrochem giant to announce its
profits in the next few minutes and it's
expected they will they will run into
the multiple billion 60 billion was an
estimate so this morning somewhere um at
a time like this when such difficult
decisions as you've just conceded there
will have to be cuts to Public Services
made isn't no the time to look again at
the windfall tax expanding its scope
making it broader and using some of that
money to plug the hole that we all know
exist in part because of what quantity
quartet and Liz trust did so I'm glad
you mentioned
um the windfall textbook there is
already a windfall test on these energy
producers
and of course that's producing about
five billion pounds of additional income
into the uh Treasury and of course we
went further because what quasi did
quite rightly was look at those who
generate energy who were not changing
anything in their model Renewables and
nuclear but whose price was pegged to
gas prices we're paying a much higher
price for Energy giving away yes 9.5
billion don't you think we could maybe
take some of that off shell and use it
to pay nurses a bit more money I mean
those are the calculations that you have
to make look if you can't commit to
expending the the windfall tax I know
that's a job to the chancellor but just
personally don't you think there's an
argument for it well as I said we
already have a windfall tax the
important thing actually is to make sure
those companies are investing in gas
assets in the North Sea this year we've
seen a 26 increase in our gas output
that's a good thing because we're less
reliant on Putin's gas
we have to well no hold on a second we
have to we have to make sure that those
companies will be incentivized to invest
so what Rishi has done in the past if
you remember is incentivize for example
the BT and others to invest in Broadband
the question of whether or not by using
your taxes we aren't going to move on
but just just finally on all of this and
before we move on to the kind of the
internal problems in the conservative
party
um James cleverley foreign Secretary of
course sitting where you were yesterday
and we got onto the issue of Qatar and
the World Cup that is taking place there
I just want to get your reviews has his
his words yesterday were to football
fans particularly to gay football fans
to be respectful of the host nation to
show a little bit of of flex and
compromise I mean was the foreign
secretary telling people to dial down
the gay if they want to go to the World
Cup no he wasn't well absolutely not so
so what he was saying is the policies of
the government are not our policies uh
nor would we condone them in fact we use
our relationship uh to make sure that
every opportunity we get to share our
values to share how we behave in this
country with countries like Qatar and
others
um but they they have their own
um culture and ways and have come to
um where they are at from a from a
different Journey it's any surprise that
there aren't more out gay footballers
when FIFA Awards the World Cup to Qatar
well look the World Cup is in Qatar I
think it's important as I said to always
what at every opportunity and I was
Vector very recently the responsible for
equalities in this country
um to make the point that you know these
values are Universal they're important
values and other countries need to go on
a journey as well should any future
World Cup be held in a country where gay
people cannot walk down that street
holding the hands for goodness sake as I
said the policies of of countries like
Qatar not heart policies nor do we
condone them uh and I think that's the
message I want to send to anybody uh
watching this program today
um let's talk about the Home Secretary
we have to spend a bit of time on this
we heard from from Jake Berry yesterday
he characterized the situation as as
multiple breaches of the ministerial
code is that accurate so the Prime
Minister has looked at this
um the Home Secretary herself if you
recall uh in her letter said I made a
mistake I'm not going to deny that or
shirk away from it I will resign she
resigned quite rightly the new prime
minister dealt with this yesterday
looked at it and he felt that she and as
I would feel she has allowed a second
chance so so there weren't multiple
breaches of the ministerial so the use
of the personal email address the
leaking of sensitive government
information sending it to the wrong evil
address I mean that that in and of
itself are multiple breaches but but
again we will ask the same questions
that were asked in the House of Commons
yesterday did officials raise concerns
about swella Braverman did the cabinet
secretary warn against her reappointment
so officials raised concerns and raise
points with uh secretary state with
ministers all the time and I think they
should be allowed to do that
um and and having you know discussions
on air about what officials advice uh
ministers I think would be unhealthy for
are for the way we we run our country
because feel free they can do that
without being quoted a public secretary
there is a security Dimension here I
mean does she have full security
clearance the homes actually has full
security clearance of course but what
I'm really trying to say to you is she
didn't you know try and hide away or try
and brush something
I claimed that yesterday in the House of
Commons it wasn't it wasn't the Home
Secretary who reported he admitted has
identified and she got sacked for he
admitted her mistake once she resigned
she resigned as she apologized and
actually people in my view I hope you
think you agree with me are allowed a
second chance
yes I understand the opportunity for
Redemption but when you're the Home
Secretary dealing with sensitive
security documents I'd say that possibly
you need to spend a bit more time in the
wilderness than six days after you get
sat for a security breach I mean it's
been dressed up as if this is some kind
of technical breach let's examine
exactly what she did she leads
immigration policy and data to a fellow
traveler in terms of migration policy
using a private email address I mean
that isn't just a breach of the
ministerial code that is her undermining
the government and for whom she served
she as I said she admitted her mistake
she resigned a new prime minister came
in looked at the information and decided
that he wants to give her a second
chance I think that's a the right
decision it's the right thing you just
said Redemption is a good thing politics
now uh you know it has been compressed
in terms of timelines because of the
change we've just had
what so if it was happening a month from
now or two months from now does this
government take people for fools it is
clear that she was only reappointed
because Rishi sunak needed to reach out
to the right of the party I mean it's
not as if soella Braverman is the
intellectual Paradise of the
conservative movement well that's you're
now personalizing being very rude about
a particular policy I think swella is
very capable uh it's unfair for you to
say that so I would just ask you to
reflect on that
she is incredibly capable to fill the
post of Home Secretary other than the
person who got sacked from it six days
ago I mean don't you understand that
there is a degree of frustration that
people have that there is this kind of
wash rinse repeat cycle in government at
the moment that someone messes up
royally they apologize and then they act
as if the apology sometimes somehow
makes everything you know peachy again
wait wait wait a second wait a second
you should apologize she resigned she
didn't just apologize keep me on she
resigned and apologized and a new
promise came in and looked at the
information decided to give her a second
this is the first time I've been here
Gavin Williamson now back in cabinet
pretty Patel sat from International Sac
from International Development back into
the home office Chris pincher you could
equally argument Boris Johnson got
sacked by the party a handful of weeks
ago and at the weekend you were
campaigning for him let me tell you why
because I called him Boris Johnson two
point North I didn't want to see
um or give the perception to the country
or to our membership that we are somehow
conspiring to keep the man who delivered
a mandate for all of us because we all
own that mandate uh being kept off the
ballot it had to come from him now I'm
going to say something to you if it does
Boris one point naught he'll probably
kept going because he had the numbers
Boris 2.0 decided to put country and
party ahead of self-interest and step
aside and support Richie sunac I'm very
proud of that that's a good thing we've
come together as a party as a family
around that table look around that
cabinet table as a Cabinet of all the
talents that's a good thing and it
should be celebrated and you may
disagree with me but I think people are
allowed a second chance and I think the
Privacy did the right thing to give
swella that second chance I will not
again though that you can see that there
were probably multiple breaches of the
ministerial court and indeed that
probably the officials advised against
her reappointment as Home Secretary but
there is a revolving door policy going
on in government at the moment
particularly in senior posts I mean
here's a question and you and I we have
spoken an awful lot over the past few
years particularly when you were
vaccines Minister we've all I've always
appreciated your calendar during some of
those interviews can you tell me how
many jobs you have had in government
since 2019. yes I can I mean I'm very
proud so I've been the business
secretary sorry business Minister I've
never made business secretary so vaccine
Minister and I'm very proud of what we
delivered on vaccines I was Secretary of
State for Education where I we did
skills schools families and I know the
Secretary of State for Education will
continue that Journey on skills name
jobs you've had nine jobs in government
since 2019 now some of those were held
concurrently yeah I will concede yes but
at the same time doesn't that
demonstrate why this government has a
real problem getting to grips with
problems as they arise plotting policy
that lasts longer than three weeks let
alone three years I mean someone like
you who has been through nine Ministry
do jobs Gavin Robinson back and back in
government Suella bravman this is not a
government that looks as if it is
performing surely so you mentioned Gavin
Williamson and I think
um I've said this on the sky actually
some time back
um Kevin Williamson did more to drive
the skills agenda t levels where you
know new and Incredibly exciting runways
for young people to get a career to get
onto that career ladder he did a
tremendous job on skills so I think keep
attacking people he's been he's been out
of government in the wilderness you're
I'll tell you what I'm going to agree
with you you're right we've had
instability we've made mistakes
Richardson said I'm going to correct
those mistakes you're going to see from
sunac a person who is reflective who's
on top of the detail who's about
sustainability of the economy and has
having a plan a plan to deliver for this
country when we have war on our
continent we will see how long that
lasts and Mr zawi it is always great to
have you in the studio so I do
appreciate your time thank you